this morning on the dish chef dave
barron he's earned an array of awards in
his career including a prestigious james
beard award and the coveted michelin
star but the most eye-catching testament
to his talent is still found on every
plate dishes as remarkable for their
visual beauty as for their creativity
and depth of flavor our jamie wax got a
look and a taste for himself
in the heart of downtown santa monica
there's a jewel of a bistro ajoli which
translates as not pretty is clearly
ironically named
and where the setting and the cuisine
capture a bit of both california and
france all of it's craton the restaurant
is the creation and showplace of chef
dave baron who gave us an impressive
demo of his approach to pleasing the
eyes and the taste buds one of the
greatest smells in all the food world
caramelized fennel is paired with a
luxurious lobster veloute piled with
root vegetables edible flowers and fresh
local herbs before a fillet of halibut
is rested on top wow perfectly cooked
halibut on top of everything else
absolutely delicious the work of a
master but baron didn't expect to be a
chef at all basically i went to college
to try to play hockey at the time your
father was teaching hotel and restaurant
management at syracuse correct and he
took you on a life-changing trip but
there was a summer when i was in college
and
he used to go to the restaurant show
chicago every year and
one year i didn't have anything to do
that summer he's like hey you want to
come to the show with me and i thought
sure i'll go it was like 20 i had
nothing better to do um and then after
that we had a few restaurants in chicago
and i was like this is really cool i'm
into this not feeling he could afford
culinary school he went straight to work
at a restaurant in michigan then he set
his sights back to where his love for
food began i had three months of
experience i don't know what i was doing
you know i was applying everywhere in
chicago thinking i can work anywhere i
worked at this one restaurant and the
chicago magazine has their like top 20
list every year back then and i just
looked at the list i was like i'm going
to apply to all of these he ended up
working at some of the windy city's most
influential restaurants including mk
true and at the globally revered alienia
with chef grant akats what's the most
important thing you learn from grant
adkids you can always do more than you
think you can you basically you're
setting your own limits i mean i watched
a guy like dying of cancer and still
coming to the kitchen you know so you
kind of sit back and say well yes if he
can do that then i can come in and be a
little tired and still work akit
survived his fight with cancer and the
two went on to partner in another
restaurant next the next was presented
to me with the opportunity to figure out
what my style of food was because there
was no style of food there it was tasty
menu and it had to change three times a
year seeking a change of environment
baron headed out west to los angeles but
at first the chef out of chicago felt
like a fish out of water the first few
visits i was just like why am i here the
city is terrible and then the more i
started spending time here the more i
realized you get back what you invest
out of la and you can have a great
dining city but it's only supported with
great diners and as i started looking
around here i started seeing people
really being engaged and dining and
that's a really magical point in the
city baron became a part of that magical
point with his beloved la pop-up
dialogue which led him to the
opportunity to open his dream bistro
just five months before the world of
dining fell apart you opened this just
long enough for everyone to fall in love
with it for it to receive accolades and
i'm sure a tremendous waiting list and
everything else and then the pandemic
hits it was terrible
i've never seen
a group of people come together the way
they did to try to keep this place open
from kitchen to front of the house like
we were trying everything everyone was
throwing out ideas but i think through
all of that we came out about a
restaurant that better restaurant now
turns out some of the most innovative
takes on french cuisine around like
their beet salad it's roasted beets and
carrots there's a
goat cheese puma under there foam
that is not at all a typical beet salad
gnocchi with base scallops english peas
pea tendrils and pea blossoms
this looks like a california farmer's
market in a bowl right right
that is a really special dish
and something pajoli is best known for
their duck dishes first up duck roulette
duck slowly roasted and preserved in its
own drippings then transformed into a
decadent spreadable appetizer the
sweetness and smokiness as well
with the crunch of the bread is just
really nice the jam kind of saves it
next is the duck press so the duck press
whole roast duck for two you finish with
a cherry vinaigrette it's a whole lot of
parts of the duck i mean the idea is
we're not wasting that's
the point of the dish that is such a
depth of flavor and a one-of-a-kind
cheesecake with a burnt exterior that
has special meaning to the chef and his
staff it's one of those magical things
where it like shouldn't make sense it's
burnt on the outside it's almost its own
sauce and the way it's creamy in the
middle it is during the pandemic we had
to sell i believe it was like 250 a
month in order to keep the entire stuff
out of my insurance i mean this is
literally this dessert represents
keeping your staff supported yeah i can
see how this kept your staff in health
insurance
we sold enough of them apparently are
you out and for dave barron the goal
isn't to keep expanding but to expand
possibilities for new culinary talents i
don't want
an array of restaurants with my name on
the door
it's not realistic i'm not at 30
restaurants i think the dream for us is
that you know we've we're developing the
infrastructure here i would love to
harvest talent what's this
that's that's the challenge to
restaurants cooks or cooks
you know you didn't start cooking to
work on spreadsheets and that's why a
lot of good restaurants fail it's not
because the food's not good it's because
they don't know how to run the business
and so if we can provide people the
opportunity to do that and grow the
brand that way
that would be the best way to do it that
would be cheers to letting cooks be
cooked
into your food for cbs saturday morning
jamie wax santa monica
so no food from jamie but we have we
have a drink voir rouge seeing red
it is beet juice gin vermouth st germain
and lemon it is on our diet cheers
online but it's all right it matches
your matches your dresses too
nice
you know we've had two french
restaurants two oh that's delicious yeah
it is it really is
but completely different
menus yeah completely different styles
it's really amazing that's the
wide-ranging style you get here it's
saturday morning i love when he says
the food it's most restaurants don't
succeed it's not because the food isn't
good it's because they don't know how to
run the business yeah it's i mean i we
talk to so many chefs all the time and
it is the one thing especially when a
chef opens when you don't have somebody
who has that business side and maybe you
haven't done it it is a business it's
not just about cooking getting people
there and that's an important part